today the orioles celebrate 21 31 the
25th anniversary of cal ripken breaking
the consecutive games playing streak of
lou gehrig and on the mound making his
major league debut dean cramer
that is how you start off your career in
the big leagues striking out one of the
best in the game the head of voigt one
and two
and he strikes him out as well
so first you get le mayhew and then you
follow it up against luke voight and
here is dj stewart
he swings and belts this one out to deep
right field dj stewart do it again
three hits on the year three home runs
this one against tanaka and the orioles
take a two nothing lead so a two down
here is the x yankee mason williams and
the pitch
snap throw to second and they get him
severino was leaning in cracks with a
heads-up
play and a bullet in the second gets
tanaka out of further trouble what does
2131 mean to you you know when you get a
certain stage of your life you look back
finally on many things you were able to
accomplish in the
um is almost one of those surreal
magical things that you wonder did that
really happen to me so here is kratz got
the bases loaded in one out
grounded to third
there's one on the first
he beats it out so that allows a run to
score three and two with two outs
strike three on the inside corner of
fastball giddy up the 2-2
that one's popped up
and ford makes the play so nice bounce
back inning for tanaka
he retires the orioles in order
hitch design as it's now called
there he just goes with a high hard one
strikes out luke voight
perfectly placed strike three cold or
you could just paint the inside corner
with a punch out how about a nine pitch
inning for dean cramer it'll be an 02 to
mount castle
and tanaka deals
cut on and hit in the air to center
field gardner a little bit toward right
center to make the catch and end the
inning
was able to capture the home run
strike three
cramer punches out another one
how about that pitch that's three in a
row punched out the last two in the
third inning and watch him dot and i on
the outside corner you see where the
bryant holiday is set up just on the
outside corner and there it is kramer so
far has been racking up the strikeouts
he's got six of them and a number of
them have been quick strikeouts
popped up
holiday mask off
makes the play
and so cramer getting into a little bit
of a rhythm after a tough second
one on ruiz at first one out bottom of
the fourth inning 2-1 baltimore
and it's nicked into the glove strike
through tough splitter from tanaka yeah
tanaka you see that's that split finger
fastball kind of spreads his fingers out
a little bit to point her finger in the
middle finger and just throws it like a
fastball and that's the typical action
from a right-hander who has a
split-finger fastball down and away from
the left-handers
sends this one to center field velazquez
going out oh nice little catch
there's a 10 pitch hitting for dean
cramer he set down 11 in a row halfway
home orioles by run here's the payoff
from tanaka
[Applause]
did he go
yes he did and stewart down on strikes
one two three in eight fortunaca who's
retired the last six orioles in a row to
be the seventh pitch of the at-bat
frazier is locked in a two-and-two count
against dean cramer
swing and a miss
six innings one run from dean cramer
worth the weight
there's a chopper left side and duhart
tried to cut over hit off his glove got
past wade and in the left
don't have james paxton right now luis
severino out for the year that what is
through ruiz found a little bit of real
estate
he goes to the slider and it is through
the left side
they'll give the hold sign to severino
as it comes in
with his first hit of the afternoon the
orioles have loaded them up 3-1
ball four walks in a run and it's 3-1-0s
ground ball
picked up la mayhew he has no play
one more comes home for the orioles it's
ruiz four to one to score
here's mike ford to lead it off
ford
hits this one
nabbed by alberto and the shift gets his
man
answer alberto
watching range well to the backhand side
how about this throw across his body
very athletic nice one hopper tanner
scott certainly appreciates it so be a
three one
and mount castle it's a fly ball that
gets the run into center hicks makes the
catch
tagging is stewart he scores it's a sac
fly and an rbi for mount castle
broken back back to the mound salsa runs
it over that's a series win against the
new york yankees